et je sais qu'il y avait eu un petit mot
avec Laurent oui tu es le mien aussi
hein
non il y a pas de souci je sais pas je
ne connais pas cette personne
[Musique]
2023 je veux un bisou je veux dire
bisous je veux dire juste un mot rapide
et ce sera plus clair ouais c'est 3h non
plus là-dessus tout ça n'est que de la
télé bien sûr
il se trouve que Jean-Marie je le
connais peu j'ai toujours entendu que du
bien de lui je connais les frères Warda
qui connaît très bien qui t'adore plein
de gens dans le métier que j'ai bossé
tout le monde t'adore il y a pas de
souci il se trouve que j'ai une
expérience avec Jean-Marie moi perso
dans son bureau un jour dans une réunion
un rendez-vous où il était avec mon
associé Franck chasinger à l'époque on
prépare une émission et c'est à ce
moment-là que effectivement dans les
délires qu'il avait à ce moment-là il y
a encore deux ans là j'ai balancé ce
truc sur Lola et sur toi je m'en excuse
donc officiellement auprès de là
notamment que j'aime plutôt beaucoup je
sais qu'elle a avec beaucoup d'humour
mais elle m'a fracassé cette semaine
mais on va parler d'addiction tout à
l'heure moi j'ai rencontré Jean-Marie
donc je produisais une émission je
demande à ce que Jean soit dans cette
émission et j'ai un rendez-vous avec lui
chez lui aux Invalides avec mon copain
mon associé qui est on avait 7 minutes
de retard je n'ai jamais 50 j'ai 60 ans
j'avais donc c'était il y a 5 ans 55 ans
je n'ai jamais été de été traité de ma
vie entière comme j'ai été traité ce
jour-là par Jean-Marie c'est que j'ai vu
un mec en face de moi qui était hors de
lui l'ancien Jean-Marie qui avait les
veines qui étaient qui sortaient comme
on le voit pas et il est en face de moi
confiance je mens pas
j'ai eu j'ai eu un choc ce jour-là de le
voir comme ça effectivement et je suis
tombé de haut pour le coup voilà après
c'est vrai que c'est cette mauvaise
image que j'avais de toi Jean-Marie je
sais que tes croyant je sais que depuis
quelques mois je n'en ai pas de
souvenirs
tu sais que tu étais dans le la aussi
était et évidemment je t'ai vu dans un
monde colère il était 17h comme je
n'avais j'imaginais même pas que
j'allais te voir comme ça mais c'était
un mauvais jour parce que je te jure
donc voilà enfin j'espère que je vais
pas me retrouver dans la position de
m'excuser si tu veux puisque
c'est ce que je dis tout
j'explique juste le contexte et tu
t'excuser c'est très bien de le faire
quand on fait le code République on
s'excuse non mais
mon cher Laurent non non tu es pardonné
j'accepte volontiers le pardon c'est la
plus belle chose qui existe au monde et
donc tu es sincèrement pardonner j'ai
pardonné à l'assassin de mon père donc
je peux pardonner à cet il y a
pas de
comment
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est l'incident éclos il
était sincère au téléphone quand il m'a
dit vraiment je m'excuse
j'en sais rien